well it got me thinking dude after your
video on Korea Tyler okay if there is
one man who can bring crypto back it's
NASA it's clear collaboration with
create Tyler Korea coin you you can buy
Korea Tyler coin crowing crowing creo
and you can create reaons yeah crayons
when you when you purchase ten thousand
crayons for twenty thousand dollars you
get a free st. Utopia NASA collab park
NASA un collab parka yeah yeah you know
that's it's so fire dude
I can't believe I can't believe the UN
was like dude this is hard I love I love
your vision right now with saying utopia
as a creative agency why don't just use
our logo yeah honestly the I [ __ ] with
the vision yeah that's what that's what
they said yeah they said let's build
yeah let's build yeah NASA NASA called
Korea up one day yeah I think his name
is Korea I'm pretty sure we're gonna
call him Korean Korea yeah Korea Jeff
Tyler Jeff Ismail name and NASA called
him up and they were like yo yo Korea
what's good he's like yo what's up who
is this oh yo this is NASA oh what's oh
what's poppin man we're just chillin
we're gonna satellite some boring [ __ ]
like that listen we [ __ ] with the vision
dude we were on your gram super dope
aesthetic I love the pink vibe you on
all the pictures hot ask girls and your
pictures by the way dude and blue eyes
water if I do say so myself we're
thinking we're kind of trying to revamp
our image a little bit with it within
the high beasts community so can we work
together what do you think for sure so
that's a yes then
yeah for sure okay cool okay cool yeah
cool cool cool cool cool so I guess
we'll start with like something made
small like a poster and then eventually
you know bring it up to
aparcar whatever yeah feel free to all
the stuffs just saying collaboration
with NASA we'd love that and then you
can keep the royalties honestly we just
want the it's kind of our an image thing
for us so yeah first sure cool man cool
all right so um we're gonna get back to
working on the satellite now I know
boring but looking forward to seeing the
posters dude for sure have fun at the
you know as it was called yeah flower
cancer house for some cloud house that's
what it is yeah for sure okay bro words
old I'm free sure yeah
sick yeah for sure I think I said this
on your stream but I watched some when I
was like when I was like looking at
digging for videos to use I found some
old as vlog that some like re-uploaded
from someone else's channel yeah and
he's just in the vlog he's not filming
yeah he's not it he's like a super
normal kid he's like a really nice guy
like from the footage yeah just joking
around being a normal dude yeah I'm like
why you got to put on this shitty
persona for when you're making your own
[ __ ] it's so weird could be one of those
things where he was like cool then and
then like something something like some
change like you know I'm saying but I
mean like it was at that house at there
that they were living at oh so he's just
Oh weird I think just like when the
cameras on he's got a probably puts on
the persona yeah it's to everyone on the
outside he's like this she's got a I
don't know he's gotta be this like cool
mysterious la dude but it's like people
just think you're scam artists but how
nice can he be if he just doesn't
[ __ ] pay rent believe that you guys
know what we're talking about it's like
the video I did most recently was about
because create Tyler posted this new
video and he tagged me in the thumbnail
whatever I watched it I thought it was
like funny I was like but this isn't
like I'm not gonna [ __ ] make another
video on this dude and then I found that
video of how much damage they did their
plays right as he was like I'm gonna tag
Cody and he's gonna do a free promo for
me you're good and then and then you're
like yeah yeah you owe a quarter million
dollars to this guy
better sell a lot of parkas my guy yeah
gotta sell a shitload of parkas yeah
that's like what how many Park is 10
$300 Barker's I'm sure like that dog
know what he's talking about how many
he's around 300 each right 300 each
hundred bucks or let's say each sells a
hundred of those things that's 30 grand
he would need to sell 833 parkas to pay
back just the term of the lease before
the damage but that's not that crazy 800
parkas that's not insane it's pretty
insane a thousand you Nellie's a
thousand units of a $300 item yeah
pretty insane yeah that's that's pretty
up there yeah you know like I'll put it
this way Cole Bennett sold a thousand
lyrical lemonade hoodies for 60 bucks
and he was elated yeah he was going like
I remember on Twitter's I oh I can't
believe this like you guys built me up
some and that's like a core following
he's built up over years yeah maybe
Korea's the maybre maybe Creon is the
master of building of audiences by not
posting maybe dude maybe he's just
[ __ ] that's that's his thing maybe
that's and then as soon as he does drop
[ __ ] people are like yeah [ __ ] cuz he
sold out of all that [ __ ] okay one of
the t-shirts with one a 100 and it was
sold out I mean I don't know how much of
this is true again you can't really
trust yeah could be fake sold out yeah
exactly but if it was was an $80 t-shirt
hundred bucks or 100 t-shirts eight
thousand bucks
I just think he's like a cereal like
Jordan Belfort type guy yeah yeah for
sure
[Music]
not trying to flex take your fishing
Norseman break that's not a flex